no recipe this is great because I've
definitely done this many times before I
[Music]
don't think anything at all actually
don't cook at all so if my dad watches
this he's gonna be super proud of me
okay I'm gonna kill this I'll be using
two eggs as it takes two to tango
[Music]
wait you're not telling me anything I
know you need flour
are you kidding wait you're serious
these eggs are warm but it's probably
fine put the spatula in the bowl you
know I'm saying really like cookie dough
so I usually just eat all the cookie
dough instead of actually making like
yeah this is how you bake you just throw
[ __ ] and I bowl and hope that it turns
out okay these cookies are about to be
vanilla e as [ __ ] baking soda is a
powder that you put into things that
you're going to be definitely failing
right now brown sugar and I have white
chick and I am quite the fan of
interracial relationships so I'm just
gonna throw both in here I'm trying to
get it to look like cookie dough
consistency I don't have a knife I'm
just gonna cut it with my hand I'm gonna
do one cup okay a little too much this
is not that bad I did such a good job
feel like I'm a caveman creating fire
for the first time
oh snap you want to lick the spoon
a lot of people like think that they're
good at baking but they're really not
this is why I don't bake house Kanaan
here oh no no no it's not really cooked
oh my god these are so good he's not bad
he's not definitely not a cookie I
probably should learn how to cook yeah I
learned respect grandma's never take the
instructions on packaging for granted if
I was on a deserted kitchen set in the
middle of a studio and had all of these
ingredients in front of me I could have
some pretty bomb cookies